floo game welcome to minecraft isn't
that right shut up shut up no one asked
oh my god it's a beautiful day we have
so much to do today cuz a big update
just came out they finally added a new
sort of fortress go away from me you're
disgusting you're beautiful kiss you how
do you get out don't bark at me we have
so much to do but before we visit the
fortress I have a couple things I need
to do very important the first things
first
it's the cartel I need to make a
smithing table ASAP because I have
nether right where is it oh my god
where's my nether right oh my god oh my
god where is it don't panic I'm
panicking a little bit where is it where
is it where is it where is it where is
it where is it oh god oh god are you
serious how do I lose it there it is
no I am sweating I found it there it is
nice okay well look for that apparently
this is the most rare enchantment in the
game I didn't know I just gave it away
to my I think I gave it to my horse
you're against murder again alright it's
gotta be it's gotta be here yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah I did not lose the most
precious item in the game don't worry
guys don't worry I didn't lose it okay
so while we panic about where I left my
most precious item in the game let me
just make one of these because
apparently how do I there we go this is
how you control the mounts in the nether
so we'll actually be able to ride them
this time yes and also let me show you
just how well my farm is working shut up
cow oh wow
full action I watch my XP watch max be a
a oh yeah alright let me heal on my
lighters healed sweet what else dude
look at that boys it worked very good do
you see that your again can I line
inside your own uragan can I
look at that I did it perfectly all
right where's I know you had it oh my
god you're a tough cookie you're a tough
little cookie I give you them elaborate
as McDow
now that I domi me tomash taka shut up
okay they have smoothing tables up here
at least I made them before there you
are how do I lose something so precious
go away I don't like you now my oh my
god oh my god this is your fault deep
we've entered an alternate universe
where you shouldn't exist and nothing
should be real I don't like it I don't
like it how how do I lose it I got to go
back on my old video and see where I put
it
I'm such an idiot I found it I found it
little piggies McGee loved to just fly
up there like Angel that was beautiful
where is it I want to dead
I want to dead I don't even know what
you are we got it got it don't ever run
from me again you smacking pecking don't
ever go near me Green bad Green bad okay
for now
finally finally yes ah yes you do it
here look at that nether I I get knocked
back resistance and more armor ooh
went on body why do I she what should I
put it on my legs I feel like the helmet
is the coolest bit so I kind of want to
put it on the helmet where it's the
armor the coolants bit what's the
coolest bed I'll put it on the helmet
just so I can I can look cool look at
that
there we go look at me dude holy Kohli I
look so cool yeah Iseman a swing where
swing not you where's Sven says huh
hey you are my little lovely smiley look
at me dude yeah I look good I look good
yeah you like that you like that okay
I'm glad I'm glad you like it
so today we're gonna visit your your
forbidden child once again Sven sorry
you can't I wish you could come with me
it's just too dangerous you dead to me
all right let's begin this journey I'm
ready but see you on the other side
Alabama what are you doing
Alabama son I come to journey your lands
once again Alabama of course I bring
offering by eating chicken in front of
you and I give you light you like uh
it's very expensive you understand this
is very good sacrifice trust me all
right first of all I want to ride those
things all right yeah yeah look at them
look at that idiot
he's just standing there what a dummy
what a dummy dumb dumb hey Tommy dumb
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb all right okay
I can only write him so now we just use
the warp fungus we should be able to
write him go yeah I shoot people I won't
shoot you you're lucky
god damn you are slow are you serious I
guess I have to take you home huh should
we take him home I wonder what your game
is gonna say about this guy don't shoot
do not shoot do not shoot
if you shoot how you done hey you dumb
he dumb so dumb all right it cannot it
cannot it can't be serious it can't go
up dude you're the most useless thing
I've ever what's wrong with you what's
wrong stop what is wrong with this stop
stop stop it
stop it stop it stop it you will never
be okay you're so ugly I can't even go
near you you will never be your again
stay there my god it's like a chihuahua
that's scared of everything
pathetic I'm not scared of anything it's
a mirror it's a field of view like very
tight and like yeah that's better thank
you
okay can you [ __ ] off dude all right so
the goal my god you're so annoying whoa
whoa whoa okay so oh god I'm not used to
this the goal is to find the new Bastion
which is the new castle in this in this
area which I'm really looking forward to
explore cuz if we can find one they're
supposed to be really good loot and I'm
excited I think they can spawn and they
worry we still need to go far enough
where we haven't gone before I'm not
sure but I think there's a new like
biome as well we'll just have to explore
this is so terrifying
they never stops being it dude look at
that it's so cool I love the nether
night now now English help me all right
let's go let's go west Oh God oh I want
bastions whoa whoa wow I am terrified I
am sweating and I'm scared all right
we're here now yes yes here good Felix
where is here I don't know death death
that's all I see all right keep an eye
out for bastions they should look like a
brick building or something like that oh
god the light just changes and it makes
me uncomfortable it makes it hard to
navigate all right we need to go far
away when you're far away from home and
you only had we have landed I should put
on some gold stuff why did I only bring
that defeats the entire purpose of my
hand where's the bastions I was
specifically promised bastings there
must be quite rare whoa
whoa look at this what is this
holy moly moly macaroni on my Peroni
what dates this what are you then black
stone my favorite what is your favorite
block of black stone dot-com black stone
calm oh god there's a lot of these I
don't like them you're not friendly I
will murder you fight me do it see what
happens yeah see what happens see what
happens yeah yeah dead I warned you I
tried to warn that you know you're not
challenged do not challenge stop stop
immediately stop it
oh god this is really unsafe to be I ate
the chicken holy cow man this is amazing
[Applause]
what is this please dude stop it please
I should have brought the soul Walker
boots god dang it wait I have I'm just
fast for some reason I will find you mr.
Bastian and I will take all your loot I
don't like this place no sir no sir I
don't
it looks insane it's dangerous there's
lava everywhere there's those everywhere
they could push you that way what is
that
Hey look at that I found something I
wish I had crossbow to murder every one
of you is that a Ches
that's just okay the temptation Felix
Felix
be careful careful Smurf oh yeah yeah I
pretended to be afraid why can they walk
in lava and not me
this is so messed up Eilis uh Oh God
it's alright I got black stone guys it's
okay it's all right now stop that
immediately stop it where oh my god he's
so far away look at this owl didn't even
hurt
I'm only crying on the inside where's my
where's my beau I don't have a beau
I lost state stop it who's making that
noise dude this thing's are giving me
PTSD you're extremely annoying and ugly
you have no redeeming qualities I will
not dead
I will not dead buy at the likes of you
okay that takes care of that I just
really want that loop okay okay oh stop
she's oh god where is where is he
[Music]
jump this is a terrible thing okay
just don't let do not pushing anyone
come now come come i dilute this mine
the loot is mine you understand that
salutis in the mine
Oh God Iren we got ayran dude I'm rich
that was so worth it hey we got a new
recipe go away go away you smell really
bad really bad super bad I am sweating
smithing dude we got golden boots I'll
take it
okay eight gold I'll take some gold
thank you we're rich now gamers all
right the journey continues I'm a little
afraid then why don't they let alone
they're easier to head if you walks
there's radiation did you hear that go
back yeah that's what I thought
oh my all right watch this hit him in
the face good what's good yeah look they
can't even see me blind Oh God hahaha
you fell for all this trick in the book
all this trick in the book put each damn
of I am not afraid of anyone
I'm like Master Chief I doesn't afraid
of anyone if Sven saw me he'd be like
damn okay there's a lot of those there
maybe that's maybe that's just an
indicator for like a cuz I know they're
their spawn ershov these now don't know
I don't like when I hear them oh my god
they suicide oh there's another one
perfect landing as always I'll be taking
this flint and steel hey you've got
mending on a hat I mean I'll take you so
that's does that mean do I have crying
obsidian I don't I wonder if that means
if we can actually put up if these works
as portals I mean that's kind of cool
right minecraft just became a lot more
hardcore I'm not gonna lie this is some
sweating in places
don't normally sweat kind of gameplay
right about here you know I'm saying
wait a minute isn't there usually gold
around those places I didn't get any
gold I want the gold god damn it doesn't
look like it oh my god
is that it that's a bastion that's
Sebastian the bastion ooh this is a
weird one
oh it is look at that this is just the
entrance oh boy oh stop that illegal you
go and lava now you go in love and
apologize so I don't get the XP
goddammit it kind of looks like a dragon
can you tell look at that does that not
look like the ender dragon
okaycome nah calm down my name cute so
what are these oh it's basalt again
stinky basalts basalt more like a fart
yeah does that not look like the N
attract gold okay I'll be taking these
thank you you know really when people
are rich they hide their goal but I
guess you just like put it out there
I'll take it thank you
that's a lot of gold yeah Oh surprise
she's in rushing in here right now okay
so where did the entrance I don't want
to fall in lava and go dead dead am I
crazy for thinking that looks like
where's it what is this whoa whoa are
you friendly or dead I thought he was
riding one of them Oh your stuff just
came out of nowhere I don't need a
basalt thank you look at its stupid
stupid face damn every time dad you're
dead now you're dead now how does that
feel to not be existing hey we're cool
we're cool I'm wearing gold boots I'm
wearing gold boots okay there's
something happening here what's going on
here guys what's going on gamers I set
you free you're free dude I have so much
gold
well will you accept the gold brick
no poor you're too poor okay so they're
supposed to be I'll take the gold by the
way they're supposed to be a bunch of
chests here but like you can find nether
and stuff which I would be like yummy
yummy heal my queen heal it Queen light
what are you doing go bye-bye
sorry about that mate all right it's
safe to go by here what are you guys
doing here what kind of party is this
shut up I feel like this one spawned in
the middle of a rock it's kind of weird
yeah look at that you so dumb you mining
diamonds with the stone pickaxe yeah
yeah we're the treasure
we're the treasure I feel like they're
trying to go to it what's the layout of
this this is so confusing oh oh oh oh oh
yes oh oh yes hmm hmm this looks like a
completely different game I don't
recognize any of this oh god I'm a
little scared it's hard to see I don't
know what's happening I want to be
careful there might be traps down here
whoa it goes deep man gilded black stone
I thought was gold and here's a wall
this is so strange I don't know because
I'm playing this snapshot they put
lanterns here is weird that I feel like
there has to be something they dug too
deep they work too greedy and they found
more than gold down I don't of the quote
this is a little scary not gonna lie
that treasure wait why are they hiding
it I think I got an messed up one
there's also above this one Oh God look
at that the lava is Lily so cool that
there's still updating Minecraft that it
makes it exciting to go places you know
I'm saying I think those are supposed to
look like tea for the ender dragon I'm
pretty sure of it
I like that there's a random lava in
here I really like that they did not
never safe are you never safe okay let's
go down here broke my leg
no problem okay this looks like oh okay
all right
oh we found 100 I'm not wearing my gold
sorry guys guys no I'm wearing gold
what's your problem
alright dead then that then dead then
they're guarding the treasure no dammit
ever that that's it arrows I'm floor
gang four arrows giving me this
expecting good loot leather actually I
need the arrows I'll take but it's not
what I want
you'll there has to be more
there's staircases where are you hiding
your gold you greedy pigs part of me
just wants to look alright and hit this
guy he's spawning they're stuck there
forever
such a strange building I can't tell
where anything is like the oh oh oh I
see it I see it I see it I see it
crossbow okay wait what do I click to
get all of them what the hell oh there
we go I did it somehow I was kind of
hoping for some better stuff cuz I have
to navigate over lava I'm not leaving
here empty-handed you understand
bye he mad Oh another one
nice come on oh what a new pig step are
you serious what there's a new song oh
you okay I understand how you hit alt I
mean I gotta bring that back well at
least there's no traps that's a tree
right there
that's a goddamn tree right there and
the stairs go here another another
little hole exciting I want gold Maria a
model who found another little nook and
cranny what is this what a Stace that's
got Pig yes
I found your stinky gold I found it I
knew they were hiding in go dolmas yeah
so that's an indicator if you see these
mod says waiting at home hoping I
returned with gold I cannot fail her she
sould polish black stone pretty cool at
least there's no lava in here famous
last words
oh my lord she says Christ Oh God
ah it's following me I made a huge
mistake ok alright ok little one it's
time to return home I mean I'm going
home you're dead okay alright
I was hoping I'd find a spawner but hey
what can you do maybe next time we'll
find more of these beautiful home at
last
Alabama you have blessed me once again I
will pay you with my most valuable item
one chicken thank you I think that's a
fair I paid my taxes hey let's trade
some gold with these guys dude I got 21
gold I mean I didn't get anything I got
nothing gold go we got some gold
shut up spin oh my god here look what I
found for you sent gold gold mountains
of gold we're gonna turn meatball into
gold baby all for you because I love you
you're the best all of yours this is
yours
this is your Iraq Kingdom spent you're
welcome you're welcome
hey shut your again you get some gilded
black stone deep you get cream cuz I
don't know you like face creams they
burn your face they'll be careful okay
how about that a successful hunt now I
really really want to play this song all
right let me find a recorder it's when I
want you to listen to this come here we
all get to listen today all rights men
listen to this all right okay okay okay
oh yeah yeah fully stacked diamonds
fully stacked diamond yeah all right
a successful adventure thank you guys
for watching this episode if you enjoyed
smash like I upload every single day
isn't that right Sven
there will be bonus video tomorrow so
I'll see you guys yeah tomorrow but
they're not normally so hey don't
subscribe 30% down subscribe alright bye
bye
[Music]
I wanna have the best of the PP to crush
the rest and get a pee Jennifer grumpy
sleepy bear reach the photo function f
on c-anca Maya to ski sword bill three
questions
boiling what you're collecting it pixel
it stumble across the world nothing from
dusk till dawn and I borrow your Power
Core my boat is down and you know Sara's
plan
Agathe comet Burke Coburn comma Molly
Claudia Rudy roller King glitchy forest
ombre lips Molly's falling what you're
calling pinging pixel ease
[Music]
no one is stronger than me
how many picture look sure you have from
breath down to crush your polish this is
my son as you know this big bad luck
will soon be gosh push to our see that
nicer up to Roxy miss for the Sally
[Music]
pink slips the crane this game of all
time download it now before to it
this song is actually a commercial I'm
spoiling why spoiling what you'd call a
king in of always falling spoiling
weren't you calling dinging house boys
boys falling weren't you calling
so late
[Music]